So yesterday, Donald Trump viciously snapped
at a nurse who is just the nurse.
She's not a politician.
She was just telling the truth as she experienced
that, which was that she had had only sporadic
access to PPE like masks and gowns and face
shields.
And Trump didn't like it.
Trump did his thing where he crosses his arms
like a petulant child.
And he snapped at her and said, well, maybe
your access was sporadic.
But that's not what I'm hearing.
Take a look at the video.
So PPE has been sporadic, but it's been manageable.
And we do what we have to do.
We're nurses and we learn to adapt and do
whatever the best thing that we can do for
our patients to get the job done and get the
care provided.
And that's what we're gonna continue to do
as Kevin, 19, continues.
Sporadic, sporadic for a lot of other things.
Oh, no, I agree.
Your president, because I've heard the opposite.
I've heard that they are loaded up with with
gowns now.
And, you know, initially we had nothing.
We had empty cupboards.
She wasn't even saying anything that bad.
Right.
I mean, access to PPE has been sporadic but
manageable.
She says it's not like a huge attack on Trump.
It's not really an attack on Trump at all.
But Trump says, well, maybe it was sporadic
for you, but not for other people.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Mr. President, she says, and of course, Donald
Trump claims this is all because of the empty
cupboards that Barack Obama left him.
And this has to be called out now when Trump
says the PPE problems were because the cupboards
were bare.
Trump's had three and a half years now.
How is it still, even if you accept it was
Obama's fault, which is ridiculous.
But even if you accept that was Obama's fault,
that there wasn't PPE when Trump took over.
It's been three and a half years.
You're telling me Trump couldn't get masks
in three and a half years?
It's really, really weak, weak stuff.
Now, I want to be really clear.
Trump doing this to a nurse is completely
heartless.
She's not a politician.
This is a nurse who treats patients.
Doctors have the Hippocratic Oath.
Nurses have the NIGHTINGALE pledge named for
Florence NIGHTINGALE.
It's similar to the Hippocratic Oath.
And a lot of ways it says, inshort, don't
do anything that might be bad for patients.
Take care of sick people.
That's what nurses do.
She has had sporadic access to PPE and Trump
can't accept it without a rebuttal and snapping
at her.
Now, I don't blame the nurse for what I'm
about to say.
She's not a politician.
She's a nurse.
It would be great if someone in one of these
situations, instead of saying yes, yes, yes,
Mr President, of course it would be better
if they said You've been misinformed, Mr President.
If that's what you heard, you weren't told
the truth.
I know the truth because I'm on the front
lines.
I'm not criticizing this nurse.
It's not her job to go there and to criticize
Donald Trump.
But it would be great for someone to publicly
do it.
A health worker in the room with Trump.
It would go instantly viral if they were to
do it.
But last thing, Trump, again, during this
photo op brings up the entire we've done more
tests than anyone lie.
Let's take a look at that.
I watch this voting.
Chuck Schumer, everyone in New York knows
he's a total phony.
He brought nothing back to New York except
salt.
They don't want salt is bad tax policy.
He brought salt back.
He didn't even fight it.
I watched him the other night on a show and
all he could talk about was testing, testing,
testing.
And yet I showed a chart yesterday where our
testing is far superior to anybody else's
testing.
And then the other thing is really interesting,
because we did so much more testing.
We have more cases.
If I did a little testing, we'd have practically
no cases.
So the headline was we have more cases than
anyone else.
Well, China has more cases than us and other
big countries.
They are talking about big countries, but
they don't want to choose.
They don't want to use that.
So I know I'm sounding like a broken record.
I will continue to fact check.
Fact check this for as long as Donald Trump
and Kaili makin any and everybody else keep
lying about it.
We do not have enough testing.
We are not the best in the world at testing.
We are forty first in testing in the world
per capita.
Seven million tests don't matter if you have
three hundred and thirty one million people.
Iceland is second in the world in per capita
testing.
Israel is 13th in the world in per capita
Portugal is 15th.
Spain is 20th.
Norway is twenty sixth.
We are forty first in the world in per capita
corona virus testing in terms of tests per
day.
Remember, health experts have said we need
to at least get to 500000 tests today to even
think about opening.
And over the last 10 days or so, we can't
get past an average of two hundred and fifty
thousand tests per day.
So after two months of this, we are really
three months.
We are.
Just now, getting half way to the absolute
minimum number we need to think about opening
and five hundred thousand tests today is just
a starting point.
We ideally would pass five hundred thousand
a day en route to a million a day en route
to 2 million tests today.
Trump is failing hugely.
It's tragic.
It's embarrassing, but he's snapping at nurses
who tell the truth.
Back briefly to the PPE thing.
There are health care workers who are dying
because they're getting the virus.
There are health care workers in places that
still are rationing PPE wearing masks longer
than they should.
For example, and Trump, who has been president
for three and a half years, is simultaneously
saying there's more than enough PPE, but also
saying any shortage is because Obama left
the cupboards bare, even though it's been
three and a half years.
It has to stop.
I